CJ and Brandon Ingram's hands Angelo
does a little dance now over to
Vanderbilt he's been on top
[Applause]
scorer here we'll get our first time out
next we will state flag Troy Brown Jr
Beasley open three got it
11-0 out of the gate behind the back
here comes the double you see a lot of
that ball movement perimeter
D'Angelo ladies and gentlemen in his 14
to nothing the football score Lakers off
to the great great start time out now
Brooklyn at OKC Milwaukee Phoenix New
York at Portland later those are the big
ones that Laker fans will be looking at
bees catching two three
and four for 16. 25 don't even need my
calculator for that one New Orleans
they're in a quarter and the Lakers
taken advantage with Brown Jr long lead
goes to the vandalorian in the front
Court
[Applause]
Lakers yes sir Malik Beasley picks it up
now now get into their action there's
only six on the clock as awesome
utilizes and hits it AR for three
[Applause]
[Music]
Russell little step back boy tell you
what
you can't miss can he uh there's they're
just shooting lights out right now from
three-point Land open man is Beasley but
Schroeder takes it instead gave her good
work by winyan there's David cat shoot
score every time I mean you could just
tell give it to me
11 out of 18 and almost half of those
are the great Acquisitions the Lakers
made at the deadline boy they are
shining is this your script it is knock
it down Malik fifth three getting almost
halfway there so far here's the thing
though the Lakers still benefit even
when he's missing because the spacing
that he provides teams are always going
to go out and challenge him
[Applause]
[Music]
he was the runner-up
from the contest easily a couple of
Misses are going to deter him is it